Hank: Hello and welcome to a special episode
of A Brief History, a show created by Ryder
Burgin that usually runs on YouTube.com/footofaferret,
but just for today it runs here on Vlogbrothers,
part of the collaboration between Hank and
Ryder.
Today's episode: Homestar Runner.
Ready?
Set?
Go!
Ryder: Atlanta, Georgia, 1996.
University of Georgia students Mike Chapman
and Craig Sobul had a day off from their summer
jobs and decided to go to a bookstore where
they discovered just how bad children's books
at that time were, and decided to just go
home and write their own.
Titled The Homestar Runner Enters the Strongest
Man in the World Contest, this book was a
quasi-parody of children's books, featuring
an arm-less athlete named Homestar Runner,
a wrestle-man named Strong Bad and a small
mischievous animal called The Cheat.
Hank: Over the next few years, Mike and his
brother Matt began working in graphic design,
while also teaching themselves Flash animation,
which allowed for animated content to beam
over the Internet back when speeds were embarrassingly
slow.
In late 1999, the brothers Chaps launched
a website at homestarrunner.com where they
would upload their Flash animation, with Mike
tackling most of the site's graphic design
and Matt voicing the majority of the characters.
Ryder: At the time of its launch, the site
featured a couple of interactive menu screens,
a few cartoons, and a handful of games.
These early cartoons had a very simple, children's-book
style, similar to that of the original Homestar
book.
These cartoons also introduced a new set of
characters who would soon become regulars
to the homestar on the show, such as Marzipan,
voiced by Missy Palmer, Strong Matt, Strong
Sad, Bubs, Coach Z, the King of Town, and
the Poopsmith.
Just...
don't ask.
The brothers continued to sporadically update
the site with new cartoons and games whenever
they could find the time to make them, but
after a couple of years and a sleek new re-design
the Homestar Runner site really began to take
off, with the launch of the site's first recurring
series, Strong Bad Email.
Hank: The concept of the show was beautiful.
Take the biggest jerk of the site, give him
fan mail, and watch the fireworks.
With its consistent release schedule, unique
sense of humor, and use of fan interaction,
the sbemails were almost an instant success,
spawning spin-off shows, including Teen Girls
Squad and of course everyone's favorite one-armed
wing-a-ling dragon turned meme, Trogdor the
Burninator.
Ryder: The Strong Bad emails massively boosted
homestarrunner.com's traffic.
How much?
No one knows.
The Brothers Chaps as they became known, never
installed an analytics package onto the site,
so viewership was then and remains now a complete
mystery.
Nonetheless, success was clear.
Thousands of emails poured into Strong Bad's
account every day, their web-hosting bills
shot through the roof, and enough merch flew
off the shelf for the Chaps to go full-time.
Hank: The Homestar universe continued to grow
with new shows and Hollywood specials and
games and collaborations; podcasting service,
DVDs, toys, posters, and a 20-track CD called
Strong Bad Sings and Other Type Hits.
References to the show popped up in Seventeen
Magazine, Guitar Hero and Buffy the Vampire
Slayer.
Ryder: With Homestar at the height of its
popularity, video game developers Telltale
games approached the Chaps about working on
a point-and-click adventure game based on
the homestar runner universe, and on April
10th 2000-and-8, Strong Bad's "Cool Game for
Attractive People" was announced for both
Wiiware and PC.
Hank: So by 2009, it seemed that the brothers
Chaps were on a roll, having at that point
released over two hundred SB-mails and created
a massive online entity from the ground up.
It seemed as if they could only continue to
grow bigger and better but then suddenly...
nothing.
Starting in late 2009, Homestar Runner went
virtually silent.
No new tunes, no new sbemails, nothing.
According to the Chaps, the silence was unexplained
because they didn't know how to explain it.
Ryder: After working on the stuff for ten
years straight, the two mutually decided to
take a short break from Homestar.
During this time, Matt moved to LA where he
began to work as a writer and director for
shows like Yo Gabba Gabba and Gravity Falls.
They never really knew how long this break
would last, but they also never anticipated
that it would stretch on for four years, and
for fans, this was less of a well-deserved
break and more of an unexpected and unexplained
indefinite hiatus.
Hank: But then, out of nowhere, on April 1st,
2014, the Chaps released their first full-length
homestar cartoon in four years.
Fans were absolutely elated, and since the
release of that 'toon, the Chaps have confirmed
their plans to bring back Homestar Runner.
Everything seems to be set in motion for Homestar's
triumphant return.
The fan community is still very much alive,
Matt's moved back home from LA, and their
April Fool's 'toon, in addition to a handful
of other new toons, showed that they hadn't
even gotten the slightest bit rusty.
Ryder: But a lot has changed on the Internet
in these four years.
Flash websites are a thing of the past.
Everyone goes to YouTube now for their online
video needs, and a lot of what made Homestar
special was it's interactivity which can't
be done on YouTube.
So how do you bring Homestar into the modern
age?
Well, we'll just have to wait and see what
wonders the Chaps cook up for us.
Hank: Homestar Runner pioneered the online
video industry, and without it, I doubt that
many of us would even be here today.
It predates YouTube by five years, yet watching
it feels as fresh and entertaining as ever.
And now, after four years of silence, Strong
Bad is finally booting up the Compy 386 again.
Rejoice, everyone!
Homestar Runner is back.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Thanks to Ryder Burgin for helping me with
this special brief history.
Check out our other collab video, a Brief
History of Harry Potter, on his channel, YouTube.com/footofaferret.